(classical string music)
- I think a typical fencer looks nerdy,
predominantly Caucasian.
So I think I'm on the
complete opposite spectrum
of what a fencer looks like, acts like,
and is in person.
I'm Miles Chamley-Watson,
I'm a two-time Olympian,
and a world champion.
As a troubled nine and a half year old,
I had to do a lot of
extracurricular activities
that was offered in my middle school.
So when I first picked up a foil,
which is what they like to call a sword.
I just immediately fell in love with it.
I didn't think it would take me this far,
but I've been rolling with it ever since.
People should know that fencing is,
it's a combat sport.
They think it's super
fluffy and all this, but no,
it's really intimate.
You can literally hear them breathing,
you can see their eyes.
You can really see if someone's scared,
or if someone has no emotions,
I think that's so cool about the sport
is you can really gauge
your opponent emotionally,
which I don't think you
can with many sports.
Well I think the fencing community,
they've embraced me but
they have people obviously
who are older who want to
see the sport the same.
People have always said,
"You won't win this competition,
"you won't make a national team,
"you won't ever, you know, make an Olympic team,
"you won't be a world champion."
I'm gonna win, and just make you eat your words.
Haters be motivators, it
just comes with the territory.
The first time I ever
qualified for the Olympics,
it's just the most incredible feeling
because all that hard work pays off,
'cause 0.11% of the population
goes to the Olympics.
I think being an outsider,
just you have more
drive than everyone else
'cause you wanna prove people wrong.
(exciting music)